lo principal y que me llevó a tomar la
decisión pues primero mi responsabilidad
como periodista como comunicadora social
Pero a su vez tenía que ver con la
semejanzas entre una situación difícil y
dolorosa que yo Viví en el año 2014
lastimosamente Valentina tres Palacios
perdió la vida después de haber sido
atacada por su pareja sentimental
ahorcada y a mí me sucedió exactamente
la misma situación en ese año por
asfixia mecánica que es conocido aquí
ese tipo de lesión o de ataque a la otra
persona y inmediatamente pues me llevó a
revivir a esos momentos dolorosos de mi
propia vida
estaba precisamente abordando ese tema
en el programa y pues no logré contener
la la emoción personal y pensé que era
el momento de abrir mi corazón romper el
silencio aprovechar quizá también ese
momento de de Pues de coyuntura y estaba
en vivo tenía bastantes seguidores en
ese momento televidentes y dije este es
el momento y un mensaje puede hacer la
diferencia Hola María Usted lo ha vivido
en carne propia fallas por parte del
sistema judicial incluso por parte de
profesionales que se supone Deben estar
capacitados para ayudarla
psicológicamente Qué debe hacerse Cuál
es su llamado
el llamado fundamental creo que es la
capacitación y que es necesaria y
absoluto medio de todo el sistema
judicial Y de igual manera con cualquier
entidad que esté disponible para atender
a las mujeres cuando buscan ayuda cuando
van a presentar sus denuncias sus
demandas si los funcionarios que van a
atender esas denuncias no están lo
suficientemente preparados en tema de
violencia de género en tipificar los
delitos pues seguramente incluso muchas
de las mujeres se podrían resultar
muertas es decir que no hay una
intervención temprana no hay
posibilidades de
acompañarlas realmente y allí es cuando
se da este fenómeno de la
revictimización es decir que la mujer
posiblemente tiene que pasar por
situaciones muy dolorosas nuevamente se
tiene que volver a enfrentar a tener que
contar su historia a uno dos tres cuatro
o hasta cinco funcionarios teniendo que
revivir ese dolor y adicionalmente si
los funcionarios que los atienden no
están preparados pues van a terminar
como como yo levantando la denuncia
porque ese fue mi caso puntual con el
fiscal quien me aconsejó
que retirara la demanda retirar a la
denuncia teniendo en cuenta que
justamente para él era violencia
intrafamiliar y eran peleas sencillas
entre una pareja y él no se dio cuenta
que quizá mi vida estaba realmente
corriendo un riesgo absoluto si él se
hubiera dado cuenta que eso no era
violencia intrafamiliarse sino un
intento de feminicidio pues las cosas
serían diferentes para mí seguramente
para la persona que me agredió no
hubiera tenido el final Pues feliz y
tranquilo que tiene en este momento y
lastimosamente como me tocó a mí le toca
muchísimas otras mujeres enfrentarse a
una justicia donde hay funcionarios que
no saben atender los casos y allí está
realmente ese hueco ese vacío que hay
que llenar de manera urgente Andrés el
presunto asesino de Valentina Ana ya
está siendo judicializado de hecho Fue
capturado Un día después del crimen y
como usted lo mencionaba muchas mujeres
esperan mucho tiempo para obtener
justicia algunas lamentablemente no
llegan a a que cree que se debe la
rapidez con la que se está llevando el
caso
Hay que ser honestos Andrés los temas el
que se vuelven mediáticos generan una
presión adicional sobre las autoridades
no estoy diciendo que no necesariamente
nunca actúen seguramente lo hacen en su
gran mayoría pero tal vez con la misma
celeridad no este se volvió un caso
mediático
independientemente de la labor a la que
se dedicaba Valentina tres Palacios pues
finalmente llegó a los medios de
comunicación Pero además por la forma
macabra atroz que que terminó siendo
este este homicidio este feminicidio y
esto Pues por supuesto genera
indignación social y esto a su vez
también presiona las autoridades ni
siquiera se trata solamente del tema
mediático sino ahora afortunadamente
Contamos con redes sociales y allí se
arma una bola muy muy grande de
indignación que termina generando esa
presión y ante esto pues las autoridades
tienen que actuar de manera más rápida y
urgente para dar unos resultados ante
una solicitud de las comunidades ante
esa solicitud de la sociedad Y en este
caso pues Es evidente que fue así y creo
que que como comunicadores incluso este
Andrés que es colega mío sabe que que
eso Suele suceder no que hay otros casos
que pueden tomarse años o incluso nunca
resolverse pero cuando hay intervención
de medios y hay intervención también a
través de redes sociales los resultados
son diferentes Ana María Vélez Gracias
por acompañarnos aquí en 24 y también
por contarnos su testimonio
Muchas gracias Andrés para usted para
Franz 24 y ese nuevo llamado al gobierno
nacional para que haya una declaratoria
de emergencia en lo que tiene que ver
con violencia basadas en género es
urgente que hay una intervención de
todas las entidades que haya